I thought every Rune bear in Elden ring
so that you don't have to there were 21
in total it was awful but one of them
was worth killing and two of them were
actually very unique see everyone who
plays Elden ring fights these things
once or twice and then just ignores them
for the rest of their playthrough
rightfully so most of them just look
like the one I'm fighting now some of
them have an absurd amount of Health
some are covered in snow some are asleep
some weight in Ambush but overall their
move sets and behavior are largely the
same except for one found here south of
the deep sea for a well in caled and one
found here southeast of the inner
consecrated snow field these two have
ragged unkempted fur which I think
suggests that they're more feral than
the others and it shows because their
moveset has all of the usual BS but it
also includes a Skyward dive attack and
an AOE Roar not only that but their
health and defense is just through the
roof especially this one in the snow
field which is basically an endgame
field boss it also just happens to be
the only bloody Rune bear that's
actually worth killing you can find it
here buried in the snow as a Wandering
Noble it's actually a mimicked here and
if you somehow overcome it you'll
receive a larval tier which you can use
to respect your character number two
while in caled did you ever notice these
piles of weapons that litter its
battlefields these I think help to
convey the sheer scale of the battle
where Melania fought radon and they're
mostly found in these sections of caled
here where Melania experienced her first
Scarlet Bloom and here near Red main
castle in the arena that I believe Rodan
fled to after succumbing to the rot we
talked really in depth about Caleb's law
in this video and it's obvious in
retrospect but a lot of you guys pointed
out that they're actually curved
greatswords among this pile of weapons
and they look almost identical to
redanes Star Scourge greatswords
suggesting that some of his soldiers
actually wielded similar swords to their
lord even though we don't fight any
soldiers wielding them in game another
curious thing about rodan's swords is
the inscription they bear which is
fittingly the same symbol that gravity
spells have the swords actually
reference this stating that Redan earned
considerable Renown as the star Scourge
in his Youth and it is said that it was
during this time that he engraved the
gravity Crest upon these blades but
what's really cool is that this gravity
Crest is likely inspired by real world
models of magnetic forces which Mark
North and South magnetic poles these
curved lines are likely the resulting
field lines that measure the strength
and direction of magnetic fields which
results in a graph that looks a lot like
the gravity Crest considering gravity
spells do pertain to the push and pull
of cosmic forces I can see the
connection though diving any deeper into
this topic makes my brain hurt so I'll
stop here
Rodan initially learned this gravity
magic so that he could ride his scrawny
horse despite his immense size then he
furthered his knowledge in order to
confront the falling stars and seal the
Fate in the night sky so naturally radon
displays this incredible Mastery over
gravity magic in our fight with him even
managing to manifest as a giant meteor
and devastate anything in his path but
the big thing we're missing from radon's
story is why he went this far why did he
have to conquer the stars and to be
honest I've always felt like we're
missing something from this topic take
for example the sword gravestone in
Celia it states that radan alone holds
Celia secure then consider the star
Scourge heirloom it states that radon
confronted the falling stars it almost
sounds as if the stars were a threat in
some way right as if radon was taking
defensive measures in conquering the
Stars rather than taking the offensive
initiative
and there's a piece of cut content that
might just explain why the story is
presented this way so in one of zully's
videos she presents evidence that
Estelle the malformed star boss might
have actually been a part of your fight
with radon this is because Estelle
actually has a cut animation that shows
them descending from the sky covering
this enormous amount of distance in the
process and crashing to the ground with
the same fiery VFX that Rodan himself
uses and while the fiery VFX is missing
from this descent Zully notes that the
animation does include fiery sound
effects making the meteor comparison
even more valid so imagine you've just
defeated radon's first phase and he
disappears from the arena demigod
defeated right the stars are free
suddenly a fiery meteor comes rushing
towards you narrowly Misses and then
unfurls to reveal astel phase two of
rodan's fight and the very thing that
radon himself self was holding back from
the world that's how I imagine it
playing out at least it would have
really driven home the idea that radon
was preventing these falling star beasts
from making planetful and it's a really
compelling Theory as to why radon might
have acted as the star Scourge in the
first place now obviously it's cut
content and it can't really be
considered Canon and I personally think
that radon's motivations can still be
more complex than just being limited to
this defensive action but perhaps this
explains why the law is so vague on this
topic almost as if the obvious
explanation was removed from the game
but speaking of radon and his Wars so
this character is the Knight gerund who
served as a commander in general radon's
Wars and he has this very curious line
of dialogue to say about EG who was the
blacksmith for the carrion royal family
bit of a haughty sort
strange fella when I knew him and funny
thing
his swords were all planted Stone but
not one of them decayed when faced with
a Scarlet wrought
we learned three fascinating things from
this dialogue first that EG carrion
Royal blacksmith actually made weapons
for some of radon's forces who
eventually came into contact with the
Scarlet rot second we learned that not
one of these weapons decayed that's
quite the achievement as Scarlet rot is
an incredibly corrosive Force even
millennia's Knights needed to have their
weapons consecrated in order to Ward it
off the only downside of EG's weapons is
that apparently they were blunt as Stone
seems odd that they'd be used at all but
I guess we just have to take that quote
at face value what's very interesting
here though is that next to EG we can
actually see a great sword which is a
weapon that you can actually loot for
yourself in caled suggesting that it
might have been one of his weapons that
made it all the way there not only that
but the great sword is actually a
recurring reference placed in many of
from software's games and it's this
homage to the great sword that's wielded
by guts from berserk a weapon that is
and I quote massive thick heavy and far
too rough it was much too big to be
because sword indeed it was like a heap
of raw iron so I wonder are these great
swords what gerund is referring to when
he talks about EG's blunt weapons Maybe
So speaking of Berserk a long time ago I
commissioned this displayed artwork from
Francois kuto and it's a blend of
berserk's Band of the hawk and
bloodborne's characters as well but even
if this isn't for you I have a whole
store filled with designs that are just
like this one except they're inspired by
Elden ring Dark Souls bloodborne Sakura
everything not to mention you can
actually get official Elden ring and
Dark Souls designs over on displayed now
as well and for a very limited time
they're all 24 off 34 off actually if
you buy more than two disc plates can
bring a ton of character to your room
they're easy to hang they have these
non-stick pads and wall magnets that
won't damage your walls so if you're
interested please click the link in the
description and consider buying more
than two prints for 34 off special
thanks to displate for sponsoring this
video but let's get back to it for
number six the Leonia maps all read as
follows the majority of Leonia known for
its vast forests and ever-present fog is
sinking into a lake
but why is it sinking into the lake the
map says that it was known for its vast
forests and ever-present fog but it
doesn't say that it was known for its
marshes or swampland so surely it wasn't
always like this what's more did the
order of Raya lucaria with all of their
Collective intellect really think to
build their Academy and surrounding town
on a swamp is it possible they were that
short-sighted I don't think so and as
for why the land is sinking I feel like
there might be two options either this
environmental change could have been
sudden and caused by the shattering with
water may be spewing down from the north
from the Altus Plateau or maybe the
place was always watery but perhaps
something else has caused the land to
soften from below so take a look at your
map and you'll notice that the lake of
rot is actually directly below Leonia
what's more if you look from the lake of
rot you can actually see a giant
glintstone crystal peeking through the
roof which I think confirms that from
software did in fact consider the upper
and lower alignment of these two places
the academy relies upon this glintstone
that they built their entire Academy on
top of so in order to claim it maybe
they simply looked past the land's poor
foundations or something like that but
anyway the lake of rot is seething it's
constantly steaming and filling the air
with its pollution so I feel like it's a
fair Theory to think that this could
have slowly eroded the land above over
time causing Leonia to maybe sink into
the lake special thanks to quailag
Linked In the description for bringing
this up to me ages ago
what do you think speaking of
environmental analysis two months ago
someone on Reddit discovered these
reliefs etched onto pillars at mikola's
halik tree they then attempted to
extrapolate meaning from them fair
enough the floral design at the lower
end they claimed depicted melania's
first second and third Blooms from which
the rot goddess emerged continuing up we
see an enclosed owl supposedly
representing Sublime Slumber enjoyed by
mikola who is in the womb only to emerge
in this elder State having quelled the
curse of Eternal childhood so this post
received over 2 000 updates and a lot of
people clearly took a liking to the
theory until someone pointed out that
these pillars are also found in Path of
Exile a different game meaning that Path
of Exile and Elden ring clearly exist
within the same universe or that from
software bought this asset from a public
asset library in order to save time and
money yeah I know it's probably that
second one actually I like that someone
in the comments claims that this
situation came about because of
apophenia which was a good word to learn
because it is a word that refers to the
tendency to perceive a connection or
meaningful pattern between unrelated or
random things and it's so easy to be
guilty of this when analyzing from
software's law you'll come up with a
theory and before long you're looking
for any evidence that proves your theory
and strokes your ego rather than looking
at all of the evidence objectively as
you should it reminds me of this video I
made a while back where I argued that
all of the soulsborne games were
canonically connected to each other as
in all their stories bled into one
another and told one big story and in
that video I was really clear that that
video was just for fun and I was very
clear that I was purposefully
cherry-picking arguments in order to
support my theories and yet still a lot
of people in the comments bought into
the idea and started to actually believe
that the games were connected so that
video now serves as a very good example
a warning that it is very easy to be
misled by someone if they're speaking
with confidence on a topic that you are
not completely familiar with anyway back
to the reliefs I'm not saying that all
architectural analysis of Elden ring is
invalid it's not a lot of Elden Ring's
architecture is probably hand crafted
with intent and you could even argue
that the public assets that from
software do use were chosen because they
align perfectly with Alden Ring's law
but I do think it's naive to think that
every single thing in from software's
games are handcrafted with intent and I
do think it's important to remember how
easy it is to be misled
speaking of which this next secret also
deserves a healthy dose of skepticism so
as they were fighting godric user Jack
newbie 555 noticed that while godric's
right leg is a mess of Flesh his left
leg is armored and it's this left leg
that godric uses to summon storm winds
for his attacks most importantly they
argue that this leg looks suspiciously
similar to Commander Nile someone who
summoned storms with a stamp of their
foot as well so How likely is it really
that godric took Nile's leg and bolted
it onto his own body well unlike the
previous secret I actually think this
one has a lot of Merit let me explain so
commander Nile is a veteran general of
Seoul A Lone Survivor who commanded
spirits to defend his long past Master
but apart from that description we
actually know very little about him and
his Allegiance and the same goes for
Commander O'Neill who is another veteran
boss of similar design but what's
relevant to us here is Nile's prosthetic
leg and its description which reads
bladed prosthetic leg enrived with the
power of lightning Commander Nile
veteran of Castle Soul offered this
prosthesis in exchange for the lives of
defeated Knights held prisoner as I was
reading this something immediately stuck
out to me why does it say that Niall
offered this prosthesis that doesn't
make sense how could he have offered up
a prosthetic leg that he actually uses
in his fight so I went to our trusty
translator Loki who reveals that the
Japanese text actually just says that
leg meaning the true description is
probably more like Commander Nile
offered his leg in exchange for the
lives of defeated Knights held prisoner
godric and godifroy 2 for that matter
are the only major players in the Elden
ring that I can think of who would
actually be happy to receive the
offering of a leg as payment for
something and Niall and O'Neill are both
missing legs which could explain both
godric and Godfrey's possession of them
so I think it's a great Theory there
could easily have been a situation where
godric or godifry held Niles Knights
prisoner leading to the offering of a
powerful limb in exchange for their safe
return the best counter evidence to this
Theory though is that godric and
godifroy are actually using right legs
as left legs here but as pointed out by
some others in the comments this
probably wasn't a deal breaker for
Godfrey or God of Roy and at the very
least if you don't like this Theory I
think that this could easily be the leg
of any banished Knight as well who were
a class of Warriors who mastered storms
and who could would have passed that
Mastery over to the grafted of all the
characters in Elden ring rodriga is the
one who was the most personally affected
by the grafting for she ventured to the
lands between from across the sea only
to barely escape with her own life
everyone's been grafted everyone who
came with me
they crossed the sea for me they fought
for me
I need to have their arms taken
their legs taken even their heads taken
taken and stuck to the spider according
to her crimsonhood roderica is
expatriated royalty from another land
and received this cloak as a gift which
made it somewhat easier for her to be
sent on her way she can be seen wearing
it in your first few encounters with her
but she soon takes it off why is that
well a great law Creator Miss chalice
proposes that this moment marks the
point where roderica puts aside her past
and starts to carve a different path for
herself she puts aside the red hood that
marked her as royalty to be protected
and takes her future into her own hands
becoming a spirit tuner at the round
table hold instead I love this theory
for more insights like this be sure to
check out chalice's content on YouTube
or Tick Tock I've been meaning to shout
her out for a while another Creator I
want to shout out again is leviathan who
points out that arena is actually
capable of casting rejection I had no
idea Leviathan argues that this is the
single weakest attack in the entirety of
Elden ring and you should check out his
video on the topic because this is
actually a part of a longer video where
he finds out if this weakest attack is
capable of one-shotting you go to his
video in the description to discover if
that is indeed possible number 11 comes
to us from user typical painter 7052 who
discovered that it's actually possible
to use America's Mischief in order to
fool the eye of Madness in Leonia and
evade detection
I mean it might take you a while to get
past it but good to know I guess these
videos have always been just a great way
for me to tell you about all of the
disparate things in the world of Elden
ring that I couldn't otherwise fit into
other videos and only recently I
realized that there's actually a
character in the game that might just
hate this idea of teaching and learning
and that's elema of the Briar we've
talked a lot about element before and
already uncovered a lot of his law he
hails from the land of eocade which is a
land of proudly solitary ascetics and he
was sentenced to death for the crime of
murdering numerous instructors and
Merchants but what's always bothered me
about his story is why he wanted to kill
these instructors and Merchants why does
he make such a spectacle of collecting
their Bell bearings and depriving you of
their items and their teachings well
finally I think I might have an answer
so the Briar grade Shield makes it clear
that element originates from eocide
which again is a land of proudly
solitary Aesthetics to be aesthetic is
to deprive oneself of all forms of
indulgence
synonymous with living a solitary life
so what if element looks down upon
merchants and instructors people who
share items and knowledge because he
thinks the world would be better off
without them he is a proud ascetic after
all so maybe he's projecting that
asceticism upon the World by depriving
everyone else of their items and their
teachings which he looks down upon
forcing everyone to rely on themselves
and nothing else I would never call this
Theory absolute fact but I think it
might just be the best explanation we
have in the absence of any other number
13 in Roundtable hold there are
paintings of many important characters
like Radigan which can be found here but
did you notice that he's actually
t-posing in this painting down here are
his hands and while they look a bit off
because you literally can't see any of
his arm I guess it's to show that his
arms are absolutely straight out to the
sides and this is important to his
character because Radigan was a very
prominent golden order fundamentalist
and this portrait makes it clear that no
one does the fundamentalist pose better
than him the gesture for Golden order
totality can be done manually if you
discover it during gold mask's questline
and it will also be performed whenever
you cast incantations of The Golden
order fundamentalists many of which help
you to kill those associated with death
like the deathbirds which is really just
an excuse for me to segue into my next
secret which revolves around the
mausoleum Knights Soldiers with
wing-shaped ornaments on their backs to
evoke the death Birds a so-called
self-inflicted curse that ties the
spirits of these loyal Knights to the
land having willingly beheaded
themselves so that they may serve their
masters in death but did you know that
this piece of armor actually has a blood
stain running down its back this is an
amazing detail that references the fact
that these Knights were beheaded credit
to user Shadow breaks who pointed this
out a long time ago for the final secret
let's return to Caleb and Melania partly
because I need an excuse to shout out
this incredible piece of character art
created by Maureen greira this was
inspired by a section in my recent lore
video on Melania where I speculated that
she might have a rebirth to come even
after the player defeats her in game and
since the rot God has a supposed
connection to a great scorpion Maureen
speculates that this could be the result
but what I really want to point out here
was that in that lore video you guys
actually noticed a piece of cut
Millennia dialogue that I missed is this
my first
it
bravely fought sir
[Music]
but remember
one day the Scarlet Bloom will flower
again
this reads similarly to reichardt's line
where he proclaims after the fight that
a serpent Never Dies so while of course
we can't be certain about how this cut
dialogue was originally planned to be
used it does seem to be another piece of
evidence that indicates Millennium might
rise again but other than recommending
that caled lore video again I think
that's all I have to say for now be sure
to check out all the links in the
description because they will point you
towards talented creators and
subscribing to all of them will just
fill your feed with more from soft
content which is always a good thing but
thank you all for watching
I'll see you in the next one